because so many of you fellow Scholars
have requested it today we are going to
have a look at one of the best papers of
the Year an incredible work that I hope
will revolutionize the creation of
virtual worlds for movies and video
games and more just imagine grabbing
your smartphone taking a few images or
videos of real world places and then we
could create a virtual version of them
and play in them in real time that would
be amazing just imagine that we could
drive on the Streets of San Francisco
and La go on a virtual hike and see what
it would look like and a ton of other
really cool things techniques that
involve rendering radius fields for
instance nerves have this as a goal and
a ton of them already exist but with
those we have two huge problems one they
are not fast enough for huge scenes in
full HD or higher resolution getting a
real-time solution is tough it typically
goes slower than that and two of course
thin structures it's always the thin
structures that are the problem now
these are quite plentiful in scenes in
the real world plant leaves cables
fences bicycle spokes that kind of thing
all thin structures yes all of those are
problems hmm now I see big words here
because this new technique promises
results more than 10 times faster in
terms of rendering time than nvidia's
excellent instant Nerf technique so of
course the quality has got to be lower
right wait a second look here are you
seeing what I am seeing the thin
structures indicate that this is not
only more than 10 times faster in terms
of rendering time but it also promises
higher quality results than the previous
methods wow and upon further inspection
this is so much cleaner so much better
and it is ridiculous how much better it
is in quality than some of the other
quite capable previous methods from just
a year ago and yes that's right now we
can get a virtual copy of the real world
with difficult thin structures go going
in full HD and yes real time much faster
than real time my goodness so good and
here comes the punchline hold on to your
papers because we should likely not call
this technique a Nerf variant because
this does not use neural networks yes
this is a good old handcrafted computer
Graphics technique wow so how does all
this Wizardry work we take out the super
capable neural networks and replace them
with a little human Ingenuity and it
gets better how well this has two key
ideas now we have a 3D World at hand
which has to be represented on our 2D
screen now the gaussian part means that
objects in this scene will be
represented as a sum of many little
lumps it is a bit like throwing a small
pebble into water the might be a small
little point but the waves it creates
spread out around this point sounds good
right well not so fast unfortunately in
the 3D space many of these waves overlap
and it is unclear how exactly they can
be transferred onto r2d screens and
splatting is a way of throwing these
little waves from the 3D virtual world
at our 2D screen and Computing what they
should really look like as an additional
Advantage these waves concentrate around
solid objects and thus this technique
does not have to waste time Computing
parts of the scene with lots of empty
space lovely idea number two typically
nerve algorithms are interested in going
through every single Pixel on your
screen and instead this one is
interested not in pixels but in The
Primitives objects in the scene now this
concept is not new it has been used in
computer graphics for decades but how it
is applied to this problem is the cool
and interesting part all in all this is
a simple algorithm it is really fast and
we don't have to sacrifice quality I
mean look at that I would like to send
huge congratulations to the entire team
and to the shared first author Bernhard
who is my former colleague and a good
friend now not even this technique is
perfect for instance rendering specular
Reflections is not perfect these light
transport effects look much more crisp
in the real world also this first
unoptimized version also consumes quite
a bit of memory however just imagine
what we will be capable of just one more
paper down the line I am a computer
Graphics researcher by trade I
specialize in light transport Ray
tracing if you will and I am always so
happy to see a good graphics paper rip
and this one this one is something
different also it just came out a few
days ago and look how it already
captured the imagination of some fellow
Scholars there what a time to be alive
if you enjoyed this episode and would
like to see many more Amazing papers
like this one consider subscribing to
the channel and hitting the Bell icon
this video has been supported by weights
and biases check out the recent offering
fully connected a place where they bring
machine learning practitioners together
to share and discuss their ideas learn
from industry leaders and even
collaborate on projects together you see
I get messages from you fellow Scholars
telling me that you have been inspired
by the series but don't really know
where to start and here it is fully
connected is a great way to learn about
the fundamentals how to reproduce those
experiments get your papers accepted to
a conference and more make sure to visit
them through
wnb.me papers or just click the link in
the video description our thanks to
weights and biases for their
long-standing support and for helping us
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time